people of the internet we just got a
surprise this morning at least I had no
idea that Minerva McGonagall was going
to be added to Harry Potter magic wagon
as a companion card she is officially in
the game and we're about to draw some
keys to see if we cannot pull Minerva
McGonagall on day one all right so
they've got all the centaurs back there
look
again
instantly transfigures all of them and
then I guess if they cast let's see how
many eight spells so they're gonna show
us casting legitimans
is that even in the game
casting that eight times and then I
assume we're gonna see the stone Soldier
here on the last one yes there it is so
there is a special season exclusive
event going on right now that is going
to help increase your chances of getting
Minerva McGonagall actually let's take a
look here if we dive into the obtain
rates Minerva McGonagall yeah her
probability is higher than anything else
except for oh wait Weasley's Wildfire
whiz bangs that one's a 2.784 percent so
you got a pretty good shot of getting
that one too but virtually everything
else outside of the rare cards you're
going to have a better chance at getting
Minerva McGonagall and then if you spend
50 you're going to be guaranteed at
getting Minerva now you can see I do not
have any red Keys here so you know what
let's go ahead and drop 900 of those
gems we've been saving them up I've got
over 2 600 right now let's go ahead and
spend 900 here we're gonna buy that
glowing key pack there we go we have 10
now and I don't know about you guys
there's just something special about
drawing it one at a time let's see how
many it's gonna take us so here we go
first draw on the red key trying to get
Minerva McGonagall
see how we do here on the first draw
three okay you know what I'm I'm good
with the cats I use those a lot I'm
happy with that come on legendary
this is our third one no legendary so
far no epic so far either oh man okay
come on come on come on McGonagall
McGonagall McGonagall
wait what we only got I was about to say
we only got two cards no we got two
centaurs you know what don't hate the
monster book that's a really good card
come on oh my goodness still no epics
got plenty of time to go one more key
see let's see let's see
oh
yes okay our first legendary here are
the things that I don't have yet I don't
have McGonagall obviously I don't have
crucio and I also do not have the orb of
water every other card in the game I at
least have one copy of
come on just one of those one of those
and I'll be happy
oh man I already have this one all right
first legendary though we've got four
left
let's go ahead and Roll It Again
come on give us another legendary
darn it
all right we're down to three left three
left right now here we go
oh no you know what this is the one this
is gonna be the one right here we're
gonna get McGonagall on this one I'm
calling it I'm calling it right now two
keys left but it's gonna be this key
We're not gonna get to the last key
hey this is a really good spell though
these Lee's Wildfire whiz bangs
all right down to our final key should
we spin more if we don't get it right
here let's go let's see it doesn't
matter we're gonna get it right here
we're gonna get McGonagall right here
I'm pretty confident in it I'm really
actually I'm not so confident I'm not so
confident now unfortunately we cannot
buy another one of the glowing key packs
so our only option is to buy them
individually which if we do that they
actually cost more on an individual
basis but you can see we are at where
are we 17 out of 50 so we would still
have 33 to go before we are guaranteed
McGonagall oh dude 150 for one and I'm
at 1762. I really don't want to drop
below a thousand
let's do one more let's do one more
purchase successful all right that gives
us one more key come on McGonagall right
here right here this is you McGonagall
Minerva come on
Minerva McGonagall
dang it all right all right all right
all right this is the one this is the
one this is Minerva this has got to be
Minerva you guys this has got to be
Minerva come on the odds are really high
are you serious you know what give me
two Ruby keys this time but that's it
that's it I'm not dropping below a
thousand we are not dropping below
actually wait 1162 we could have bought
one more but you know what we're not
gonna need to buy one more We're not
gonna need to buy one more because we're
gonna we're gonna get McGonagall right
here we're actually gonna have an extra
key we're gonna have
all right last key for real this time
for real for real for like for real for
real for real
oh my goodness
at least we got two epics but seriously
dude no McGonagall oh I can't do it man
I can't buy that many more keys I want
to save those gems I got to be careful
with those I can't believe it we're
actually gonna have to end the video
without getting Minerva McGonagall well
guess what you can't make this up guys I
stopped recording play some duels get a
golden key and look who I get out of it
McGonagall I kid you not one golden key
and we get McGonagall just crazy how the
odds work sometimes am I right you know
what let's jump into the training mode
and actually test this companion out and
see how McGonagall works in the field of
battle all right so let's go ahead and
put let's see two three four five six
seven eight let's just put a ridiculous
number out here I wonder if there's a
limit actually how many you can put go
ahead and give us unlimited MP unlimited
movement cards because I think we need
to play eight cards which seems a little
high and that's eight cards for her to
summon the stone Soldier seems a little
high to me though but let's take a look
and see if I just play her right here
off the Jump
no way it transfigures every one of them
what that is crazy and then today okay I
need to see that on enemies I wonder if
they actually just stand there all right
now I need to throw eight cards so
here's one
here's two
here's three
here's four
here's five
six I'm trying not to do a lot of damage
on them over there because I want to see
how McDonald's does seven
and then eight
all right so now let's see if she
summons the stone Soldier oh there he is
okay so he basically looks like the pure
totem locomotor but just one of them so
then she keeps casting
and he's just like going crazy I can
already see some builds that people are
gonna be running with the actual pure
totem locomotor card plus McGonagall
or even if you're like Bellatrix or
something and then you get Death Eaters
on the field along with these two and it
looks like she kind of hangs back while
he just goes to attack there all right
so I'm gonna hop into a practice Duo
duel see if we can't get just a lot of
enemies on the field maybe a lot of
summons and then throw down McGonagall
and see if she instantly transforms
everything I'm also running the pure
totem locomotor myself this is practice
mode so even though they're banned right
now we can actually still run them all
right so let's let's cast her right now
there she is instantly oh my goodness
everything gets transfigured I'm gonna
oh McGonagall
all right let's see if they take her out
let's see if they take her out we need
to take out the Thunderbird back there
okay that's gone dude what a terrifying
sight
I can't stop laughing a giant McGonagall
and two giant Stone soldiers and as soon
as I cast eight cards they're gonna be
even more she's gonna summon her own
let's go and do another swelling
solution come on McGonagall I should
have been counting my cards to see if I
had oh man we're gonna make these people
so mad oh there she just summoned the
stone Soldier okay
dude this is actually insane I'm just
gonna let them revive I don't I don't
want to actually go too hardcore on this
okay they are not prioritizing
McGonagall at all who knows maybe we're
just playing against bots I have no idea
but they haven't really doing anything
to her she has five HP left
but that was actually some insane damage
especially if I would have been you know
actually trying to get that elimination
after we okay they finally took her out
there
but that was a lot of fun I can see
people having so much fun with
McGonagall especially when you get three
of those soldiers going
just absolutely crazy that's gonna do it
for today's video guys as always thank
you all so much for watching and I'll
talk to you again soon